The Season 1 finale of "1883," the Paramount+
prequel series to Paramount's "Yellowstone,"
might just be the most heartbreaking episode
in the entire "Yellowstone" franchise.
First and foremost, there are two major character
deaths in the finale, both of whom successfully
reach the end of their respective journeys
before passing.
The first is Elsa Dutton, who, after being
gravely wounded by an arrow, makes her father,
James, promise that she can pick the spot
where she will die.
She ends up choosing a small tree in the gorgeous
Paradise Valley and dies peacefully in her
father's arms.
The scene is gut-wrenching and tragic, though
the episode's second major death is by far
the more brutal of the two.
In a time skip forward, we watch as Shea Brennan
finally completes his journey to the West
Coast, and sits on a beach in Oregon to watch
the waves crash against the shore.
It was revealed earlier in the series that
Shea's only reason for making the journey
west was because of a promise he made to his
wife, Helen, who desperately wanted to see
the ocean.
"Just look at that, Helen.
Isn't it beautiful?"
Helen died prior to the series' start, so
Shea took it upon himself to let her see the
ocean through his eyes.
Shea's promise is finally fulfilled, and after
staring at the waves for a while, he kills
himself so that he can finally be with his
wife once more.
Given how well audiences had gotten to know
Shea throughout "1883" Season 1, his death
is undeniably sad.
Although, there is a silver lining that makes
the scene a bit less heartbreaking: the unexpected
appearance of a hummingbird on the beach,
which flits around for a moment looking right
at him, as if it's trying to get his attention.
It doesn't stay long, though, and when it
leaves, a smile widens across Shea's face,
who has finally found peace in his final moments.
The "1883" Reddit community naturally began
speculating on what this scene – and the
bird itself – means.
A prevalent theory is that the hummingbird
symbolizes someone visiting Shea from beyond
the grave – specifically, his late wife
Helen.
It could be that the hummingbird is indeed
Shea's wife, who comes to see him at the end
of their long journey to Oregon.
After all, seeing what was supposed to be
their adventure through to the end was Shea's
driving purpose all along, so it makes thematic
sense.
Still, other fans seem to believe that it's
actually an entirely different deceased character.
One Reddit user wrote,
"It was Elsa.
The symbolism of the hummingbird is the epitome
of her...
Remember her talking about birds in her final
moment?"
Other users referenced Elsa's conversation
with Shea earlier in the episode, which seems
to foreshadow his meeting with the bird.
As one poster wrote,
"Elsa did tell him to save a spot for her
(at the beach) if she didn't survive."
It seems entirely possible that the hummingbird
is meant to symbolize Elsa coming back to
visit Shea just like she said she would.
"Come meet ya on the beach."
"I'll save you a spot."
Then there's the third camp, which includes
people who just found the whole scene absolutely
tear-jerking, and didn't dwell much on the
symbolism at all.
Calling the scene "sad but also beautiful,"
one person posted,
"Shea on the beach with the hummingbird really
[got] me.
[...] I know his body and soul were tired
and he was ready to be with his wife and daughter."
Other users wrote that they loved Shea and
Elsa's connection throughout the first season
of the series, all the way up to the bittersweet
end.
Regardless of who the hummingbird really is,
its appearance is undeniably heartwarming
and makes an incredibly emotional scene even
more powerful.
Shea Brennan's life was dominated by war,
loss, and sadness, which compounded to create
the gruff, no-nonsense attitude that became
his trademark.
At least when he sat on that beach, looked
on at the vastness of the ocean, and had the
chance to breathe just a little easier, he
didn't have to do so alone.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.